okay guys I'm opening up Chloe's
Mother's Day gift and we're off to a
pretty good start
one of-a-kind gives throwback photos
heartwarming messages and tons of
flowers the kardashian-jenner crew
couldn't be together to celebrate
Mother's Day this year but they still
manage to make it special I'm really off
for my mom being happy that's like all I
could ask for whatever makes her happy
the matriarch and the family Kris Jenner
took to Instagram to show off Chloe's
present to all the moms in the fam a
quote mommy's little quarantine kid and
tops it off with Wayne is a sexual
Kourtney Kardashian also showed off the
kit and captioned it quote only khlo
would think of this Chloe who is the mom
to two-year-old true gave a shout-out to
her grandma MJ for being the queen who
started it all
she also shared this sweet photo next to
Chris caption and get quote my mommy my
inspiration it's my favorite part about
being a mom I mean it's so corny but
it's just like no matter how tired you
are whatever you just it's complete
bliss Chloe received a huge table plant
from her sister Nev that she says it's
quote more beautiful in real life this
comes just two days after Chloe and son
Mason Disick tp'ed her house Hey look at
this what do you think about it on
Instagram Kourtney shared a heartwarming
post about the gift that motherhood has
brought her saying quote my biggest
blessing the three that have given me
purpose make every experience better
test me teach me and remind me of Who I
am in the truest sense their mother I
think of anything having kids teaches
more than you really can understand just
one day after she celebrated her son
Psalms first birthday Kim
kardashian-west
woke up to breakfast in bed two roses
and an adorable home a card that
featured cutouts of all four of her kids
hands the card read quote happy Mother's
Day
2020 love North st. chai and Psalm in
Kim's Instagram story she wished a happy
Mother's Day to her grandmother MJ mom
Kris Jenner and sisters Khloe Kourtney
and Kylie Kim also included that
throwback clip of Kanye performing hey
mama a dedication to his late mother
Don de West at the 2008 Grammy Awards on
Friday Kim shared her early Mother's Day
gift to mom Kris she posted this photo
of Kris and a bikini along with the
video showing off her gift Mother's Day
I surprised my mom with the most amazing
photo album from her wedding
photographer alfred garcia in 1977 that
she took he took all these amazing
photos at my parents wedding and i
contacted him and i bought the camera
from him that he used at my parents
wedding day because kylie jenner kicked
off Mother's Day by watching frozen for
the one hundred and twenty seventh times
she shared two adorable pics of stormy
captioning them quote this little love
of mine what a special gift it is to be
a mother happy Mother's Day to all the
Mamas she also posted this fierce photo
of Kris Jenner captioning it quote a
legend
Kylie got an early start to her Mother's
Day gifting last week she sent her
sisters Sheena shaped clutches
completely covered in crystals the
clutches made by Judith Leiber each
costs more than five thousand dollars
[Music]
kendall Jenner the only family member
who hasn't taken on Parenthood yet share
this throwback video of her mom playing
tennis in a pink bikini captioning it
quote love your mother so your mom is
the ultimate mom boss yes to celebrate
the holiday Kristin her kids boxes of
Krispy Kreme she also shared this photo
of the family captioning it in part
seeing my babies become mothers has
brought me so much joy and I thank God
for my family every day so my beautiful
daughters who are moms Kourtney Kim
khloé Kylie I'm so proud of you today in
every day last year et toxic Kourtney
Khloe and Kim about the possibility of
expanding their family even more and I
don't then right now I'm super content
with just true yeah and I guess I guess
just I have to see in the situation I
don't feel it it's I don't know one and
done yeah and I'm I never thought I
would have only one child but I am so
obsessed with her and I love it so much
I definitely don't think I would feel
incomplete if I did it more but another
one we just had
it's gonna be it's hard because it's
like a family making kind of family yeah
but you just have one I know the best
everything that is it really isn't that
the only thing was I just like born to
believe I need to have so many kids I
don't know but I'm so happy with just
her
[Music]